Do you think that you would have a civil war?
Are you worried about that?
What do you think will happen if we do nothing?
Do you think more kids will be killed?
I'm not, I'm not arguing on behalf-
Do you think more concerts will be shot up,
more churches will--
I'm not arguing on behalf-
The court keeps allowing states to ban assault-style
weapons.
Your inability to do even the common sense
stuff really frustrates me.
So when do we say enough is enough?
A string of high-profile mass shootings over
the past few years
has spawned a movement that’s calling for
new legislation
to outlaw so-called assault-style weapons,
in particular the popular AR-15.
Assault weapon bans are depicted as life-saving,
“common sense” policy.
The problem is that the definition of an assault
weapon is totally arbitrary.
An assault weapon is whatever is covered by
an assault weapon ban.
Jacob Sullum is a senior editor at Reason
who writes about gun policy.
The criteria that are used to identify assault
weapons
are things that have little or nothing to
do with how useful or how deadly
an assault weapon is in the hands of a mass
murderer.
We will finally ban these assault weapons
from our streets
that have no other purpose other than to kill.
The federal government banned assault weapons
in 1994,
when President Clinton signed a bill sponsored
in the Senate by Dianne Feinstein.
Mr. and Mrs America, Turn them all in.
The bill expired 10 years later, but Feinstein
is sponsoring a new version of the law.
Meanwhile, seven states and the District of
Columbia
have enacted their own assault weapon bans.
There’s little evidence that the 1994 legislation
reduced gun deaths,
in part because it was mostly a symbolic gesture.
Unless you really delve into the specifics
of what these bills do,
you don't understand how utterly arbitrary
they are.
In the original 1994 bill and in the new version
of the legislation
assault weapons are not defined by what they
do but by how they look.
Feinstein's current bill talks about things
like pistol grips, adjustable stocks, threaded barrels,
in other words, you can have a gun with any
one of those features,
it is now an assault weapon.
Exactly the same gun without those features
is not an assault weapon.
And in fact, there are a bunch of examples
like that.
Let’s compare the Ruger Mini-14 Ranch Rifle
with the AR-15.
One looks like a hunting rifle and the other
looks like a military weapon.
They fire at the same rate, they fired the
same caliber of ammunition
and because they have similar barrel lengths,
the ballistics are almost identical.
Now those are single shots.
If I wanted to fire this on full semi-automatic,
all I do is keep firing...
Another misconception is that so-called assault
rifles are automatic weapons,
which fire continuously until the trigger
is released or the gun runs out of ammunition.
The federal government banned the manufacture
of new automatic weapons
for civilian use in 1986.
Most modern civilian guns are semi-automatic,
which means they only fire one round per trigger
pull.
But if you're talking about, you know,
how many rounds you get out of the gun within
a certain amount of time,
any semiautomatic is gonna fire be capable
of firing the same number of rounds
Originally built for the battlefield,
a defining characteristic of the AR-15 is
the speed and power of the bullet…
Another myth is that assault weapons are more
powerful than other guns.
In reality, the power of a firearm depends
mainly on the cartridge, not the gun.
Again, compare the Ruger Mini-14 Ranch Rifle
with the AR-15.
Both can shoot the same .223 caliber bullet,
at the same velocity.
You will see that lots of hunting rifles are
more powerful,
uh, can do more damage, uh, you know, at the
same distance,
uh, than so called assault weapons.
One of the most common cartridges used for
hunting is the .308 Winchester,
which has more than double the impact force
when compared to the ammunition used in an
AR-15.
Another common refrain is that assault weapons
can inherently fire more rounds than other
guns before reloading.
But it’s the magazine, which is just a detachable
box and a spring,
that determines how many times you can fire.
And many guns that are not identified as “assault
weapons”
accept high-capacity magazines.
So again, this is not a feature that distinguishes
assault weapons from other kinds of guns.
Banning guns solely based on appearance is
counterproductive
and makes it difficult to have a good-faith
discussion about effective solutions to gun violence.
I’m not going to say everyone has to own
an ar-15, because it's such a great gun.
But people have their reasons for wanting
to have them
and the government shouldn't be second-guessing
those reasons
without a very powerful justification.
And the justification offered for banning
assault weapons is virtually nonexistent
because it doesn't make sense.